hi I'm Alvin and I love video games I'm
Joe and I love pizza
and I thought could be a fun idea to
recreate a minigame from Mario Party in
real life it's called to me Mario it
requires precision hand-eye coordination
and a giant pizza have you played this
game before I've never even seen the
game I gotta be real with you I don't
know what we're about to do I guess it
sounds like we should probably go play
the game first done let's go all right
so we're gonna start playing and this is
on the lease or a reminder you gotta
have that safety strap safety first
all right who you're gonna be Joe I feel
like it would it be weird if I'm Mario
they're gonna be Mario I will be Luigi
the goal of the game you are assigned a
topic and you need to get at least one
of your toppings on every single slice
of pizza and whoever gets it first wins
yeah all right easy enough
this seems like it's telling you to like
do this flicking topping motion is that
how you put toppings on pizza that's
exactly how you do it in the restaurant
all right you ready let's do it he's
pretty simple so it sounds famous last
words
oh god this is hard just like in the
restaurant one piece of cheese on every
slice do you really have four people
making one pizza no labor on that just
well disregard that you got one more
left dude you want oh wow that is crazy
okay so to recreate this seems pretty
hard there's a lot to do we have to make
a big rotating like lazy zoo but it
moves automatically I'm spinning it and
the food I can handle the food okay so
you got it I'll take care of the food if
you can make a table two spins I will do
my best
all right Joe you ready let's do this
[Applause]
we're about exciting Alma check it out I
got this giant pizza dough almost the
size of the one exactly like the video
game tomato paste painted on there so we
have our individual slices and then
we're surrounded by topics Wow pepperoni
broccoli mushrooms and the individual
mozzarella
just as authentic as they are in the
game and so for the setup we have the
camera angle set up to kind of emulate
the way that the video game looks and we
got the big Pizza rotation in the center
and we also have the sort of stations
and these mats that represent the color
of each player and where they have to
stand so I am very excited this looks
like the game it looks just like the
game except we're not gonna have two
computer players many friends
we do need friends let's bring in some
friends wow we're so conveniently placed
write-offs remember - what do you guys
think of the setup this is already
impressive honestly have you guys seen
the game you know what we're about to do
I have yeah it's gonna be very messy
okay so ground rules if you guys just
need a refresher everybody gets to stand
on a master you each have a bowl to your
left which is your assigned ingredient
everybody has to toss the ingredients
only one at a time on the pizza we're
gonna toss underhand like the Wii Remote
we're gonna have to land on the tomato
paste slice your topping completely
inside not overlapping or on the white
at all for it to count when you think
you have all of your toppings on the
pizza call it out like bingo you guys
are ready to play yeah you ready to lose
to your stations mine are all landing in
the same spot oh this is so hard
you're missing that we did anybody did
anybody
mushrooms are closed your place that's
out if you cut that slice the mushrooms
gone yeah see he knows I'm missing three
all right so this one is this one in
mind I need one more I say yes we're
gonna go back and we're gonna spin I
think I'm gonna weigh I don't know you
got you got a call if you lose you lose
[Music]
I see the one I'm missing oh I think I
got it let's figure out where we at Joe
it's a value at you first
I'm very confident one 1 two 2 three 3
four 4 5 6 okay so Joe's got it but I
think a lot of us got it all in the same
moment we might have Nietzsche you want
to go to let's see we got to - we got
three I'll give it to you yeah really
tone the line oh sorry well for that guy
that's very high six Kelsey
okay that's okay sure yeah way crazy
yeah so you're missing one Nietzsche is
missing one everybody else's are pretty
flat objects whereas mine have a lot of
dimension that you're running off the
way it has always how am i doing let's
go pepperoni one
- is this in or out four five okay okay
all right see how it is Nietzsche I'm
much more hanok it's Mario Party it's
not a party
yeah it looks like Joe mario has won so
I do actually want to see how it tastes
it's in the game they don't eat it
they just do make it should I go cook
this yeah maybe we should go bake it
I'll go up throw it in right thanks
Mario so Joe thank you for making the
pizza for my giant pizza oven I mean a
game that you can then eat like good
yeah I'm very surprised what you guys
came up with but also not surprised for
this tasty you guys crush it I think the
fact that you kept going
made sure each pizza has more than one
to be a pop I think cool toppings on all
of these yeah it almost looks like it
took us all about three or four try
until Andy's going hot all right shall
we eat some shop let's taste Cheers
it'll bring it in oh that's why we don't
put broccoli on pizza that's why we
don't put broccoli on pizza I haven't
stopped yeah
I'm eating great work guys well this was
fun and if you guys want to see more
food content where you make stuff from
video games make sure to check out my
friend Incas video she makes a curry
from Pokemon it's pretty awesome and let
us know what other video games and foods
you guys want us to recreate or have fun
with let us know what you guys want us
to do next and see you next time soon
later
I was very good waiting the whole time
[Music]